thank you
Panama's 130 kilometer long that Yang
Gap is one of the world's most dangerous
jungles
it's partially populated by small
indigenous communities
but an unprecedented wave of hundreds of
thousands of migrants making the
perilous Journey Across The Gap in an
attempt to reach the United States is
threatening the once pristine rainforest
Ikito population 300 is receiving
between two and a half thousand and five
thousand migrants a day and the impact
is obvious
Eduardo Mejia an indigenous Community
policeman or Sarah was born here
the water up river is contaminated with
clothes and the dead bodies of the
migrants that don't make it so we can't
drink the rear water anymore we can't
even eat the fish
vultures are now everywhere attracted by
the odor of human excrement and rubbish
The Village which has no sewerage
electricity or potable water simply
cannot cope
at the first aid clinic Dr Ariel
garibaldo expresses fears of an outbreak
of diseases like cholera
this is a place where an epidemic can
break out at the snap of your fingers
because of the overcrowding conditions
in such tiny space where people are
arriving from all over the world we have
no way to deal with an emergency
the migrants are mainly from Venezuela
but also from as far away as Bangladesh
Africa China and the Middle East the
indigenous Emperor people have been
living here in this jungle for hundreds
of years these children for example
learned to swim before they could even
walk but while this all may look very
idyllic the tsunami the constant
entrance of thousands and thousands of
migrants is not only threatening the
health of this area but also these
people's way of life
indigenous leaders of four Villages want
to end the chaos
it's important that these migrants be
put into a special Camp so that they do
not mix with the local people because we
don't know what they bring and they can
also be sleeping with our women and
impacting our culture but a great many
villages insist they're also benefiting
from the weight of migration people like
Esmeralda who has set up a food stall
and provides Wi-Fi services
it's helped the whole town a lot and the
other three indigenous towns along our
River because we women are now selling
food and that helps our children in the
family we make a lot of more money now
business is so good that many in the
community have abandoned their fields of
bananas corn and rice
beyond the benefits and drawbacks of
this phenomena the majority of people
here want the government to enact
changes and improve conditions not just
for the migrants and Transit but to the
indigenous communities of the Darien Gap
who've long been forgotten to see a
human Al Jazeera Daddy and GAP Panama
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera